all right I'm gonna get started so my
name is Jeffrey Beck I'm one of the core
developers for pandas I've been doing
this for a couple of years actually and
using my old joke so Wes gets all the
kudos and I get the hate mail so that's
how it is so anyways if you've come in
late this if you want to follow along
the there's a link there to the actual
repo you can clone that for the
presentation okay here we go
alright this is gonna be a little bit
more of an intermediate level tutorial
there are and and I will show you on
here so here's a couple links I've also
put up this parts of this tutorial are
taken from tomahawks burgers PI data
Seattle tour tutorial which is a little
bit more on the beginner side so if
you're just starting on with pandas then
feel free to take a look at that there's
also a video online I've also included
some links throughout this presentation
to most of us to the documentation
actually there's a few external links to
get more information
pandas is a fairly large library
actually and there's a lot of topics so
I'm gonna attempt to give you a brief
tour of pandas and parts that you may or
may not have seen before I'm going to in
particular focus a little bit on
performance I have another talk that
I've done that goes in-depth on
performance but I will hit some of the
main points in here okay so if you are
following along installation this is
actually using 3/4 you can use whatever
it'll work on three to seven as well a
bunch of libraries that I'm going to
mention at least and then you can
there's a whole requirements file in the
notebook itself sorry bigger sure
better yeah I'll do a little bit bigger
half the problem is so the problem is
making everything fit on this screen is
actually it takes a lot of time but I
will try I'll blow it up as as needed
how's that okay all right so this talks
to the consists of essentially six
notebooks I'm gonna talk about getting
your data in and out of pandas then
looking at your data will go through
group by essentially reshaping type
operations
we're gonna hit time series and then
we're going to talk about using pandas
in concert with some other libraries
that are built upon it or use it anyways
okay all right importing data so you
have nice data and okay as a almost all
my slides have is the top just a couple
of standard imports numpy and pandas I
usually set the sum of the display
options simply just to make sure things
show up on the screen we are using
pandas 17 released about a month ago
okay so you have data in a lot of
different formats pandas currently
imports and exports from all of these
different formats we're actually
probably going to add a couple more
things more in the Big Data stack like
Avro soon we'll see and I'm gonna at
least briefly mention most of these okay
so part of the sample data set I'm going
to use is no longer available but I have
a gzip version on here in CSV format if
you're interested in the parsing of this
data set it was kind of gnarly actually
Tom did it and you can look at his talk
I don't know why they removed data sets
it's kind of strange but just about it's
about beer reviews
okay so CSV
everybody has CSV data they want to read
it in they want to parse it they want to
do it fast so here's a link to how to do
that so standard CSV you read your file
we automatically you can infer certain
types of compression
there's explicit options for this in
fact there's about fifty options that
you can pass to read CSV it's not nearly
as complicated as it looks most the time
it just simply works standard things you
might need to do specify a column to set
as the index you can certainly do this
afterwards but it's sometimes convenient
to make it in a single statement date
parsing you need to be explicit about
this pandas can guess at times we're
trying to remove the notion of just
guessing everything but it'll make some
pretty good guesses in this case this is
actually an encoded data set which makes
things a little bit annoying
okay so this just we're just reading it
in notice we I generally show the
display this shows the summary of how
many rows and columns we have I've
scaled this just so we show it on the
display correctly okay so this is what
we're gonna use for a lot of the
presentation okay so the first thing
it's useful to look at our info which is
the basic a summary display showing each
of the columns how many non Knolls you
have and what data types they have we're
going to pay particular attention to
these data types as we go throughout the
presentation if you take I'll give a
couple of Nuggets but if you take the
first one is that you really really want
to pay attention to your data types
object data it holds certain data types
in other words you want to hold for
object data type only strings if you're
holding other stuff it will work but it
will be pretty much non performant if
you have float data you want to make
sure it's floats don't make don't have
it as objects so you really want to be
careful about your data types strings I
see this all the time you want to make
sure they're really in the base type
that pandas and numpy like which is
date/time 64 nanoseconds okay so we'll
talk about this more in depth as we go
this is an encoded data set certainly
possible to deal with things and we will
okay so I'm going to go through a couple
of many examples where we're just simply
going to write them out to sort of
temporary files
and all of the data types or all of the
import formats that we talk about
provide both an importer and an exporter
generally it's to underscore the format
or read underscore the format okay so
Excel provides importers and exporters
and you'll notice that most of the
signatures of these functions are very
similar
generally they take a file object or a
file like object and then a generally a
bunch of parameters and for the most
part they're pretty similar like whether
to write the index or not whether it
encode things or not of course like in
excels case as an example you can choose
to read a single sheet in so some some
of these formats have special parameters
okay so we look so going back we looked
at CSV or we just did an example on CSV
and I'm gonna show these all at the end
when I time them Excel so sequel is a
funny animal you need to actually give
it in this case we use sequel alchemy
you need to give it an engine but
otherwise it's very similar in its basic
form anyways to import your export from
anything else JSON same idea again for
the most part the default options might
work for you there's a lot of options on
how to handle automatic conversions of
formats how to actually write the JSON
and in other words what the write record
first or row first or whatever one of my
favorite formats actually is hdf so this
is hdf5 it's a scientific format that
was originally propagated by the
astronomy guys and it's great because
it's binary
it's it's a fairly a standard format of
course there's there's a lot of metadata
associated with your actual data files
and this is both good and bad good in
that you can provide pretty much a
seamless transition to and from hdf in
other words it has pretty good fidelity
it's bad because if something else is
trying to read your data it doesn't
understand the metadata that's a problem
example I've seen many people oh I
really want to use h5
with pandas and the answer is right now
you can't we use pie tables underneath
to write this format you could actually
read it but you can't actually write in
a chive pie and then read it back in
pandas this might change the future
actually as a chive pie and pie tables
are undergoing some essentially merger
that's good so first thing you try to do
is write it in h5 pie or sorry in hdf5
and the first thing comes up as a
warning and you're like oh this is not
fun so I'm just note I'm actually
writing the fixed format here this
essentially writes a single block of
data and it doesn't allow appending nor
querying I normally write in the table
format I'll explain why I'm not doing
that in a second but pay attention to
warnings we don't give them too often in
pandas in this case it's basically
saying well we're gonna look at these
three columns that it's telling you
about it says oh these actually have
nulls in them and so this doesn't like
it fixed format is but basically it
pickles your string data which actually
is it's okay it's fine it works
however there's Nan's in there and
pickle it pineapples this view doesn't
like this because it essentially becomes
a mixed data type in the single column
okay so there's number ways around this
you could fill it if you wanted to for
now we're just going to ignore it and
it'll work actually okay so okay now the
reason I'm not writing this in table
form and I prefer table form and this is
a effectively an on disk representation
of a data frame which is pretty good
actually in the sense that we can have
roundtrip ability the only difference
here is that you're storing it as fixed
length strings so everything has to
become the length of the maximum this is
fine for a lot of data in this
particular data set so this is why I'm
just taking the text column and we're
basically finding a vector a series of
the lengths of each
field the length of the text for that
particular entry and I'll go into this a
little bit more but my point is that so
we have 15,000 entries and we have a
maximum entry of 4900 characters so the
problem is we have wildly varying length
strings so in fact if you tried to write
this as a fixed light string this would
be a problem it'll work actually but it
makes a gigantic file compression can
actually help with that but in this case
we're not going to we're not going to do
this and there's a lot of solutions to
this but we're not going to deal with it
at this point time so some timings for
various methods this is 50,000 records I
think by thirteen column something like
that so Excel is pretty slow sequel is
better JSON is okay
CSP is pretty good hgf is actually a lot
better be like oh that's great
but there's actually two more formats I
really didn't mention we can coarse
pickle a data frame and I'll go through
a couple of reasons why or why not you
want to do this in a second and then
there's a format called message pack
which is essentially kind of like beasts
on it's a binary json almost okay these
are actually much faster even even than
hdf so just you can think about using
these there's a lot of different formats
so you pick what is useful so I put a
couple links up here so one is Matt
Rocklin he's the author of tasks he did
a basically study of using essentially
all of these formats plus more storing
text data and numeric data and if you're
storing text data the bottom line
conclusion is you want to use JSON
mainly because everybody else does it
and it compresses pretty well if you're
storing numerical data you don't want to
use JSON you want to use luckily a
binary format like an HD F or even a
message pack something like that further
I'll mention the the odo library this
library actually provides essentially a
set of converters to and from more or
less frames and numpy arrays and
basically lots of other things much more
so than pandas does things like like
HDFS and
three and they actually support us three
now - okay did I miss no I did okay so
when you have larger datasets sometimes
you'll want to chunk your data okay we
can do that you can provide a chunk size
so you essentially get a list of frames
you can do this primarily with CSV and
you can do this with hdf5 and so you
then you can operate these out on a
chunked manner I'll go through some
strategies for dealing with out of four
data at the very end okay so a lot of
questions here so what formats can we
use for various things how can we query
them what had you know what can we put
over the wire and various things so one
of my big things is you want you know
once you clean up your data I generally
want to store it in a format that you
don't have to clean it up again when you
read it back in and even things like
sequel you generally have to it's pretty
good nowadays especially when you use
like Postgres you can read it back in
and it'll be very it'll be identical to
what you you sent out you won't have to
do any post conversions when I say post
conversions is you want the drivers to
handle these things you want them to
make you know proper day times when
you're actually reading back in so for
the most part it's pretty good so I
could have actually put sequel in that
category and the first one right up here
today but of course you when you have
larger data sets you want to query the
data yes you can query a CSV but it's
non performant you can do it but and
then of course sometimes you want to
iterate over bigger data sets in our
operative bility is important to lots of
folks we we all have lots of data in CSV
format it's just how it is now you may
often times want to take your data and
then put it in an intermediate format or
something like that okay so you didn't
review these okay next now we're gonna
talk about examining your data okay so
again we're gonna have our standard
imports at the top of the sheet and I'm
so the data that we've saved before in
the hdf5 I'm reading back in and I'm
gonna do this pretty much at the top of
most of the sheets so again we're going
to see that we have all the data types
are
specified in other words we have our
this time field is a date time 64
we have various float in the ins and so
on and so forth
and I'll go through a couple these in a
second all right
so panis provides a lot of ways of
working with particular D types okay
so text data is stored as object okay
now the reason this is sort of useful is
because you can do things you know hold
on I didn't read it in just a second
all right okay so we probably things
called accessors which allow you to have
d types specifically data via the
accessor so you know the methods that
will work on that type of data if you
have float data you're not going to get
this this is not going to work so in
this case we have object type data and
then so I can operate and get various
functions on here so we use that should
this length function before this simply
counts the number of characters in that
entry and there's a ton more okay so a
big thing of pandas is to do operations
in return what we call an indexer in
other words essentially a series that is
like index to your data in this case I'm
gonna say okay take this take this field
and say okay does it match this red X
and if true but true if false put false
and we can use that for selections later
on so a lot of the interactions your
data will be constructing indexers and
we provide so next we just talk about
text very briefly we're gonna talk about
the DT accessor so this is how to
operate on date/time like data actually
works for period in period data time
Delton data and date/time data okay so
this is our original column it's in day
time 64 and even though this says time
here that's just the name of the column
we're using this dot DT accessor and
we're actually accessing the date here
and of course we have a bunch of fields
these are of course specific to date
time accessing themselves if we had
actually time Delta column they would be
specific to that so in this case we're
actually pulling out the date object and
these actually are date objects so you
would normally not even do this this is
not a recommended thing to do but maybe
you want to explore this look at it or
if you want to group by this it's
actually pretty efficient but a lot of
people tend to work in they say oh I
have just dates but you all always
always always want to work in day time
in 64's okay you might want to convert
it or do some
operation on but you never ever ever
want to iterate on things like this okay
so so essentially my second nugget of
wisdom here is that you if you're ever
find yourself iterating over something
the answer is a vectorize or B do
something else because iteration is just
like Python iteration you can you need
to do it sometimes of course but in
general the reason pandas has is highly
performant is because we can keep things
in numpy arrays and we can operate them
on on them using you thunks and in
highly efficient methods so the point
here is add a time date date object is
actually not a first-class object in
pandas it never has been I don't think
it ever will because it's basically a
Python object so every time if they do
anything you have to do a lot of
indirection to get to it it will work
it's not efficient okay going back to
the acquisition so the reason you want
to do this is maybe I want to pull up
the hours hypothetically here who's
sorry
okay I'll show you a use case for this
later we want to do things like so one
thing you might want to do is do
something like this I'm gonna again
construct an indexer or constructed
boolean array that's absolutely the crux
of pandas when I want to select data I
just want to couldn't construct various
indexers and then combine them together
okay so here we go another type of a
data type is categoricals these are
relatively new in pandas categoricals
you could think of as as really like
text data but they fit in various
categories so you can actually think of
categories in the statistical sense
where you have say like male or female
have do you have two categories so we
use them for that we export them to
things like Patsy in that way however a
big use case of categorical is actually
is to represent a relatively small
number of values in a very efficient way
okay so if you have you know it doesn't
know how many values you have if you
only have ten categories we can
represent it very efficiently but
essentially by mapping them to integers
and this is all happens under the hood
so
taking all of our text columns so this
is another method relatively new called
select D types
you can basically take your frame and
say hey give me only certain data types
here they have an include and exclude
field so example we were looking at text
where it has 50,000 entries and there's
4,000 49,000 you know odd unique so all
that's not very useful but if you look
at the beer style cat
you only have 104 unique so well that's
great because I can represent very
efficiently and that's what we're gonna
do next step here so one point to note
there's this memory usage thing when you
look at a data frame it has a little
plus on it and that is to tell you that
hey you're storing object data and you
may be actually having a much bigger
memory footprint than you actually think
you do in fact storing a single object
generally takes like something like 40
bytes
it's a crazy for each character in there
for each element so the problem is this
is just how it working you know you
think you have a numpy array an object
array and you just have a single pointer
and that's what the the value we're
showing here this is 50 thousand times
like 8 bits or whatever or 8 bytes but
it's really not that because that object
actually has to be stored somewhere in
the Python system and that's just not
it's just not the actual length of the
string it's really a lot of information
which some enables Python to
garbage-collected so storing objects can
be quite inefficient so to combat this
we oftentimes will turn things into
categoricals this is an actual real
estimate or real number I'll say of how
much memory this is actually consuming
and the reason for this is what I said
before we were basically factorizing
things and if you guys were in Andy
Miller's talked earlier in effect this
is the same thing that they do we call
this factorization they call this I
think they call it count factorization
is something like that it's the same
idea and what we doing is were
essentially mapping integers to things
strings okay
so we have categories and we have codes
this is all essentially the
implementation diesel you don't have to
really understand this just know that
it's pretty efficient okay so I'm gonna
yes yes hdf5 stores is sufficiently
essentially we're storing the integers
in the table and then we're storing a
side table which has the categories map
back then
unfortunately exhibit like you can't do
this in CSV CSV is you just store the
strings I mean you could do it if you
wanted to but then you're responsible
for the bookkeeping and that that's
really crux to the problem it's you can
do any you can do anything but if you
want to make it easy for yourself for
your users then you have to do the extra
work so the one of the points of pandas
is to make it easy and natural you for
you to do things and hide the details
you have a nice language feature
essentially and you just it just works
that's at least one of the ideas it's
not always like that but we try all
right I'm gonna go briefly through
indexing okay so I mentioned before
we're trying to construct bullying
indexers or indexers oftentimes they're
just bullying values in other words you
have a series and you have you know
true/false for each one great simple we
did this in a variety of ways before
this is the I think this is the average
percentage of alcohol in the beer
alcohol bye-bye yeah okay
so here what we're doing is we're saying
okay let me select all the beers that
have a relatively low alcohol bug on
okay so I'm just simply indexing okay
now what we were doing now this is cost
so when you do the single bracket it's
called get item this can take a boolean
indexer like this okay
however I'm gonna really recommend that
you use dot lock for pretty much
everything the main reason is you can
then specify it doesn't have to guess at
what you're really trying to do you can
be very explicit you could say okay I'm
going to
index the Rose here right here and I'm
going to select the columns and I want
these two columns here you could put a
different index or for the columns if
you wanted to but I'm just telling I
want these getitem is very convenient
there are some will say quirks in it to
make it sort of more interactive namely
you can do things like we actually
select columns using get items so you'd
be like oh I'm selecting rows or my
selecting columns and so it does some
inference it figures this out but if you
want to be very explicit use dot lock
okay
okay so again we can string these
expressions together this is very much
like a sequel query I'll show you that
in a little bit okay these use a numpy
like syntax of you know ands and ORS and
you have to use parentheses to group
unless you have a single one than you
don't so yes so when you're looking at a
frame you have an index all frames in
series have an index if you don't
provide one explicitly or overwrite it
it'll be what's called an integer index
simply enumerate in your columns
numerating your rows okay um you can
have duplicate data and we'll talk about
that a little bit on how to deal with
that in this case it's a unique index
okay and there are various methods for
dealing with that and there's sometimes
you want that as much you don't okay
okay so in general in this case so this
this is of course of pain point in
pandas right now so what is a data frame
a data frame is essentially a collection
of numpy rays the implementation right
now and they could be possibly different
D types in general you want different D
types simply because you want to hold
heterogeneous data numpy array in
general except reviews record raised is
a homogeneous d type so think of a data
frame as effectively
not exactly but effectively a dict of
individual each column is eith like
series like object it's a single numpy
array it's not actually implemented like
that and I think we're gonna change this
at some point in the future hopefully to
be I will say more transparent so going
back to your question these are almost
always views but not always and that's
the Rob and it's weird somewhat
dependent upon what numpy tells us to do
so what we're gonna do is give you a
view of each column and this is totally
highly performant it's great except when
you try to assign it to this and you've
probably all seen this setting with copy
warning I put in a couple versions ago
and we'll just briefly mention that
essentially once you filter something so
if you have a view of something else and
then you try to assign to this well what
do you want it to do do you want me to
propagate that or not and the default
behavior just give you a warning because
I oftentimes don't know what to do so
we'll have to we'll talk about that a
little bit yes no it's always been that
way so it's always been that way yes yes
here's the answer it used to work but
sometimes it just wouldn't work that was
the difference that's why we put the
warning there because you could actually
end up with a copy and you were ended up
of signing to a copy and then that was
like oh where'd of my you know I signed
something it just didn't change so now
at least I'll give you a warning and you
have to deal with okay so again the
bottom line is you want to create
indexers so we're gonna use this other
function called is in this does just
what it thinks it what you think would
do except here we're trying to take a
categorical column and say oh we're
trying to actually to do a string like
method on a categorical column so this
is an open issue of course so this
should work actually it doesn't
so we're say okay what can we do we have
these great categorical columns what can
we do
alright so one way of dealing with this
is to convert it back to an object
column okay it works okay is there a
better way so with categoricals so now I
just want to mention I'm gonna be using
this type of style and I recently
adopted this called method chaining
and essentially you put these little the
parentheses around and you can
essentially almost do arbitrary white
space around your method calls the
reason I like this is because you can do
stuff like this so it's very easy to do
things like edit this and say oh go
whoops no I'm supposed to work I
probably didn't execute something here
this is why you should never do my
presentation there we go this new this
notebook thing is this is called rise by
the way it's so it's a live presentation
of the slideshow it's actually pretty
cool
then you can edit it and of course
helped you it makes you added it so here
what we're doing is we're saying okay
tell me you know take this take this
column which is a categorical column and
say okay tell me the now I'm indexing
the categories of the column itself and
says okay tell me which one the ones I
want so I want to select this list right
here or I want to select this I'm
returning the ones that I want to get
okay great and I sign that to the verbal
cats then here I can just simply use
izan isn't takes a essentially set
operation says okay tell me what's in
this and it creates an indexer for you
and then I can just simply index it okay
alright so we can do this with any
number of things so value constants a
very convenient method to essentially
count the values and it ranks them by
the most prop popular to the least
popular essentially a frequency analysis
here okay so now I'm gonna do something
like okay I have these beer IDs and you
see that the top three here are these
guys and here I'm gonna take the top
three just because I decided to now the
key thing is I'm looking I'm saying okay
take the top three and I'm give me their
index okay oops go back here so these
are the top three but actually what I
want is the index of these okay and then
I'm gonna use this isn't on that to
select essentially the top three most
popular ones out of this whole frame
okay I'm just gonna briefly tour the
sort of the methods of indexing there's
a lot of documentation on this so I'll
just briefly mention some of these just
so you can know them
so there's head and tail show me the top
five bottom five you notice I've not
been really using this because by
default I'm going to show
essentially the head and tail more or
less according to the max rows that I've
shown but you can still do this I lock I
lock is the positional indexing
equivalent of lock except it completely
treats everything as a positional
indexer entirely it ignores all the
complications of well maybe I actually
have an index which is say 2 4 6 8 okay
and so the problem it occurs is like if
I give you 1 2 3 what does it mean do I
want Nan's do I want you to select the
first second and third elements so to
avoid this complication we have
essentially two methods indexing I lock
is for integer call it energy or
location indexing and lock which is for
label based indexing ok these work on
the index in this case I said I want the
tooth the second fifth and tenth element
they happen to be so the index happens
to match that in this case I could
change that and so I'm also doing things
you can of course put slices in there
saying give me the same element but just
give me the column slices oops ok so I'm
gonna I'm gonna preempted one of the
questions I'm going to ask is there's
this other indexer too called IX this is
a combination of integer and location
nexi and the reason we've not deprecated
this it's actually still useful
sometimes you want to say okay give me
the first 10 rows and but then I want to
name these columns it's kind of
convenient
we don't highly recommend it because
there are some edge cases and the main
one is that if you have an integer index
that is not simply you know the
enumeration of the rows you can get
unexpected results so you can certainly
use and it has its use cases so location
is actually this will give you its now
here it's not looking at the second
fifth and tenth row I know it says that
but it's actually looking at this is a
label not a position it's all you need
to understand it's a label everything is
a label okay and here I'm doing some
combination of label based indexing and
you can always pass a building the index
these okay so this was the question I
said why do we use IX because sometimes
you want to do some combination of
integer based and label based indexing
okay now there's something very
important in that this index that we're
dealing with is unique okay the reason
it unique this is important is we can do
hash table based lookups when you do
index it's very fast that's great but
sometimes if I'm swimming some setting
index it's not unique okay it'll still
work actually but it's a fair bit slower
it's a little bit less intuitive what
you're doing so in these cases we're
going to go to a hierarchical indexing
namely multi indexes don't be afraid of
both annexes they're very friendly and
they're very powerful so you can do
things like so here I wanted what I want
to do is set the new set these three
columns as my index and we have a sparse
if I'd view of this so in other words
this is the these are called levels so
this is the it's actually called the
zeroth level the first level the second
level these gonna have names they have
names they happen to the names of the
columns okay and one thing to note about
multi indexing is you
they always must be lexically sorted
they don't actually have to be it'll
still work in general you almost always
want to do that to make it perform an
otherwise we'll throw a performance
warning actually long complicated reason
why for this okay
so why is this useful because now we
just set this index right here this
thing called the reviews and now it's
unique it was not unique before so now
we can do very efficient lookups okay
we're gonna use this in a second so here
I'm again I'm gonna show you here yeah
so here I'm saying give me all the
values in the index itself for this
level give me all the values so 50,000
lengths one for each one value count
them
and then give me the top five we'll call
it a top five reviewers we did this a
little bit before and so now I'm using
Locke and I'm saying okay this is
actually incorrect syntax here but see
it'll act this will actually work okay
okay yes it is right there's some
ambiguity of what I'm actually doing
okay so here I'm saying essentially I
mean indexing by those top reviewers
that I did
okay so just and that's elected this
many now I'm going to so now I'm going
to pick out a particular value I'm
giving it a tuple so multi indexes are
represented by two pools and you can
fully index by them if you specify you
can specify actually a list of tuples in
this case I'm only specifying one now
where this gets um this useful okay is
where I want to do multi access indexing
so we have this notion of a thing called
an index slice it's just it's a really
simple object to avoid having to type
these little slice objects the whole
point of this is to enable so remember
lock has you can index in the rows and
the columns potentially simultaneously
so here I have an additional
complication because now my index is
composed of three sort of levels so I'm
using IX to differentiate of what I'm
doing here so this is a fully specified
index err on level zero and I'm actually
level also a level one here okay
and I'm also simultaneously selecting
only a certain number of columns okay
something we're going to introduce not
so recently it's called query this is
actually a very convenient method
unfortunately have to it has to be a
string but we do allow things like you
can use this a little at sign to inject
actually variables into the scope a
little sort of hacky trick there but the
advantage is you can almost write a
sequel like syntax which some people may
find useful okay okay
okay so the reason this is useful as you
couldn't do this before we had what we
call multi index slicers so here I'm
selecting only on the second level
I'll just put one caution up there you
have to fully specify all the levels
even if it's by a colon there was you
have otherwise it becomes a little bit
ambiguous of what you're trying to do
you can actually leave off the last ones
but you gotta put the first ones there
in the future
I think I have a slide for this no I
don't we're gonna love this to be select
like a dick like syntax which should be
a little bit nicer this case okay next
section I'm gonna talk about group eyes
okay using the same data set that we had
group by what does a group by group I is
fundamentally three different operations
splitting applying a function and then
recombining the results okay so you can
group by many things usually you want a
group I like you can group by a column
you can group by the levels or multi
index but you can also give things like
you could actually have a function you
could give a dictionary or series like
object that has a mapping it could be a
completely arbitrary mapping could be
anything
this is where things can get it quite
interesting so group by just creates an
object doesn't actually do any
computation it just gives you an object
back and we'll I'll show you how that's
useful in a little bit okay there's a
lot of operations you can actually do on
a grouper itself you can say oh how many
groups do I have you can actually
iterate through groups I don't normally
recommend this but in this case I'm just
showing you the first five group is
always done in the ordering of the of
the original order of the frame okay
we're not like Reese or ting anything
it's simply an indexer effectively into
the frame itself I'm just printing this
column's thing just to reorder the
columns in a bit so ignore that okay so
what are we actually doing here I said
okay give me this group and then show me
the columns in order and
the reason this is exactly like this
it's just simply a selection it's all of
this everything you notice is in the
same order of course this is very
inefficient comparatively because we're
construct where essentially you have to
go through everything to find the result
so by grouping we pre computed this set
okay so once you've grouped then we have
we can perform a effectively a combined
step here and apply and combine so we're
going to execute a function we're going
to do something on each group this can
be either a reduction or it could be a
transformation I'll show that in a
little bit okay so in this case what do
we do we said okay we're taking the mean
of every group the what the thing that
we were grouping by ends up as your
index here and I'm going to show you a
couple of different ways you can utilize
this it's very flexible you can apply
your own functions here I'll just
caution that when you're applying your
own functions in effect what you're
doing is a loop over the groups if you
have a smaller groups great nope no big
deal if you have a large number group
sticks it can be highly inefficient and
we'll talk about that a little bit so we
can do things like select a so actually
on the group by object itself we're
doing a sub selection I don't want to do
the mean of to have you know hundred
columns I only want to do mean of these
ones okay we can do that we can do just
a single column and this will return a
series this is effectively like just
give me one column but in this case in
order to get this you to get this back
as a frame - I don't know if I have this
hooked up here you could do this yeah so
this gives you a frame again it's the
same notion of lookup in a data frame
versus a series okay so the reason this
is useful is again we have these chain
type operations so what we're gonna do
here so again I'm going to group by beer
style give me the
average by volume alcohol by them and
give me the standard deviation again
it's in it's in the order it happen to
be alphabetic order fits the order it
was and then let me sort it okay
yes yep
the answer is yes and I'll show that in
a second actually the other thing to do
here is of course you could do this we
could do you know it could pass a
function here yeah this is actually a
function instead of standard deviation
I'm gonna do like this is this is you
know kind of silly but this can be
anything but again I'll caution that all
the functions that are sort of having
are near already named these are highly
efficient they're all implemented scythe
on there are so this is not going to be
quite as efficient because what we're
doing is we're calling it on e we're
essentially doing a loop so but if you
don't have a lot of groups it's probably
fine and there's various ways to deal
with this and we'll talk about that a
little bit okay so just as we did a
single aggregation now we're gonna do a
multiple aggregations here you can just
put a list of functions you can give a
lot of cases where you can give a name
you can also give a numpy function you
can actually have lambdas in here as
well you can do notice that this just
gave back a simple frame and we'll look
in a second here so oh I think we did
this already okay skip that so we can
also do multiple aggregations this gives
back a multi index okay so here we've
said for each column that we're looking
at give me back the main count in
standard Asian okay and we're good we're
going to reshape this in a second all
right
but you have a hierarchal index some
people don't like working there with
them directly and some you know
sometimes you want to reshape it okay so
let's talk about doing that so this is
the result from before remember we group
by to get this and we have a two-level
index I I just named them characteristic
and measure because I couldn't find some
good names to that so these are two
different aggregations these are
stacking so what we're do
a stacking is very simple you're taking
the columns and you're shifting to the
index okay and I did it two different
ways here I said okay I'm going to shift
the characteristic to the index here I'm
going to shift the measure to the index
and whatever is left is left if you get
two different ways of looking at your
data now there's also a none stack stack
and unstack are inverses of each other
so stack and stack get back your data
okay going back so sometimes it's very
convenient to have my frame with the
multi index you can also group by multi
necks
you can either use positional indicators
it could use level zero or you could use
the name so here I'm actually going to
do so this is the stacked version that
we did before then I'm going to group by
I'm gonna select the this is a column
now and then I'm going to aggregate so
what do we do here I mean this is also
crazy thing but in reality there's a
number of ways to do things but again
we're going to set up pipelines to do
things okay so not only can we group by
a single thing we can by multiple things
and this necessarily gives you back a
multi index of the result and think
about this so we ended up these these
are sparse fide group here now here's
something that people say okay oh let me
group by something and then let me in my
apply let me group by something else so
I've seen this written like this
I mean to
let's see so this is highly inefficient
and I have seen a lot it does that
basically the same thing
okay there is no reason to do this ever
it will work actually you probably have
to do some stuff but in any event try to
keep the stuff inside the apply
extremely simple and I'll go through an
example this in the end it just makes
life simpler and it's it's more it's
easy to read to okay this was an
exercise from the original tutorial I'll
just sort of give you the answer because
we don't have so much time so just as it
just as we've been grouping by the
columns you can also group by an
arbitrary function or anything that has
the same length as your frame so in this
case we're going to group by the length
of the text completely arbitrarily here
so we are grouping I'm passing a
function here this generates a series
actors what it does but the series
doesn't happen to do this to my frame
it's just an arbitrary one I created
we're selecting a single column out
we're doing the meet of that and we're
doing a funky plot of that okay so
fundamentally word this is the column
we're constructing and then we're
grouping by this has you know some
arbitrary number of groups okay we're
gonna go over transform in a second but
to summarize there's essentially three
methods you can apply to a grouped
object you can aggregate you can train
so aggregation is generally a reduction
transforming is just what it sounds like
you are taking every value on the group
and transforming into something else on
a per group basis apply you can do sort
of what you want and we'll figure out
what you want
okay now AG is there's a lot of
shortcuts to AG things like dot mean
whenever I do that I'm doing an
aggregation okay so okay so a typical
transformation would be something like D
meaning per group okay so we can write
it like that if we want and if you
actually do this on a series okay we're
this is almost trivial right all we're
doing is taking the series and
stretching the meaning that's not what
we want we want to do this a per group
basis so we could simply transform it
with that function okay so per group
we're gonna do that
however it's oftentimes much better to
actually on what I call in wrapping the
group by so you could write that exact
same operation as a series of just take
the data from itself and subtract a
transformation with the mean of the
group okay and I'm just doing it select
D types because if you don't do that you
will be at this this actually does take
a couple of seconds so you'll see all
these these columns we don't care about
you know we don't care about text
columns but in this case we're the group
eyes will normally exclude these type of
text columns okay now the reason this
matters you can get a fairly substantial
performance boost doing this this is of
course completely dependent on the
number of groups if you only had a
hundred groups this would be like you
know hundred times faster so it's
actually function the number of groups
so you know okay
next thing we're gonna address we don't
run on time here okay okay so barring
from our friend Hadley Wycombe basically
he's the author of deep liar and are you
generally want to have set up your data
such that it's essentially a long-form
type of data you want to have one row
per observation and then your variables
form a column you don't want to have
these conglomerated columns names you
can certainly and a lot of pandas power
is to transform that stuff to a
long-form type of data this is how you
know generally you might keep it in a
database or not okay so we're going to
use this example here I'm not going to
execute this but you can actually pull
this this as using the reh tml returns a
serie a list of tables actually to get
this is I think MBA data from 2015
here's what it looks like this CSV I
don't know if I haven't repo or not but
you can just simply download it's not
that big so we have it again a messy CSV
now we're going we're going to read it
in a second we're going to try to answer
this question how many days have rested
each team get between games
this is a messy thing okay
now it's a lot it's it looks a lot
messier than it actually is simply
because I'm trying to keep the width
down here but again I have this okay so
this is just a simple read CSV and I
just simply I said I only want certain
columns okay so far this is pretty raw
data I'm using this fairly new method
called a sine and what this does is is
will in line in the method Cheney create
another column copies the data for you
this is exactly equivalent to copying
the data assigning a new column and then
returning it but we can do it in the
method chain in this case what am i
doing I'm actually taking the date
column so yes read see is we could
actually parse these dates in line but
I'm just doing this as example I'm
taking from before so we had actually
dates and times we're not sure you to
use the times but I wanted to put them
together just because it looked cool so
here we're actually stewing a string
concatenation and then we're parsing it
oops right here okay and I added this
column on called date and this looks
like a date I'm 64 nanoseconds it is
drop some columns and set the index okay
so oftentimes you'll have such a
scenario where you're reading your data
and you're doing a lot of manipulations
and then you're done great
so put that off in a function call the
function and move on okay so here's our
basic data what am I doing here I'm just
signing some index names it's not
interesting okay so there's two methods
I want to introduce you to or if you've
already seen them you'll you'll be
excited melt and PIN it's okay so here
we're gonna take Y data two long data so
let's go here I'd say this is y data
because we're doing things like away
team away points home team home points
so you'll notice that these that we have
1236 rows here for columns we're going
to do this
thing okay and we're gonna basically
transform it we're going to go like this
with the data okay this actually comes
from our it's a nice little do this
every a lot of things come from our it's
not bad and the now just just to prove
what we did here so this created
duplicates okay and I did it on purpose
I'm not indexing off yet but I just did
this on purpose so we effectively took a
row and we split it and we added it on
to the to the long set here okay and the
inverse of this is long too wide it's
simply a pivot so a lot of people are
familiar with pivots where you have
value in a column and you basically in
effect you group eye on that and shift
it like this and well I'll show that in
one second so that's kind of the inverse
of melt
all right so now we have our data in the
tidy form so now we're going to do
something we could say okay let's group
by our team get the date dip it and get
the number of days and I'm going to show
that I'm gonna unroll this operation in
a second okay so this is the result this
is how we did it so I said okay I'm
showing this for one team here I'm
grouping binds and get to get to the
Lakers and I want to then get the date
column and then dip it so I'm taking I'm
doing the shift operation so I'm taking
my day column shift and up by one
subtracting it I get a time delta column
then I happen to be taking the date so
the number of days in that subtracting
one fine
that's days of the rest okay now I
oftentimes want to visualize my data so
this is this relatively new operator
called pipe which is extremely
convenient and this is the reason I'm
writing this method Cheney type of stuff
I could pretty easily just comment these
two lines out and shove them to you know
to matplotlib or to bouquet or to
whatever and it would be very easy to do
and of course this is effectively
equivalent to something like this
oops sorry that's not what I'm going to
do
so I could have written it if I put the
fasiq grid stuff outside of here it
would have done the same exact thing but
that's a little bit inconvenient and
that's why I'm using this piping notice
this map actually is not a panda's map
actually this is operating on the result
of this this is a seaborne function so
what are we plotting here I'm gonna go
through that in a second but we are
plotting for each group we're plotting
two things and we're doing a nice little
graph of each one okay so this is
effectively the same exact thing I was
just doing this if I'm doing it for one
team just so we can see this I don't
know an easy way to make that bigger but
I can go like this this may be and just
to show you what C board is actually
doing they're actually doing an internal
group by okay and they're doing this
some divided by count okay so these are
the values actually they're showing up
here just to show this in a nice
visualization no pipe actually sends the
result of the prior operation to this
we're handing we're handing Seaborn a
data frame okay a fully-qualified divet
it doesn't actually take a group on by
object it actually does a group by
internally is what it's doing actually
but just for simplicity I'm just showing
one single group here again we're we're
basically sending it belong form data
that's what everybody expects so that's
what we want to give them and let them
take it from our pipeline okay this is a
little bit more involved example a stack
I'm going to skip this actually for now
just keep in mind I'm gonna show you one
thing over here this actually goes
through how to do merges or how not to
do merges just because I'm gonna run out
of time if I don't do this you can do
some crazy merges this is a merge of a
merge of a merge and you can actually
pop to yourself but and I don't know go
through so if I Python people this
actually becomes trivial you can use a
map function and to avoid merging so
this is actually a really convenient
from a syntactical point of view makes a
lot of sense so this is what a series
map does that
it's almost like a do the merge on
itself okay anyways this also goes
through a more a couple of types of
pivoting but and how pivot does but I'm
gonna just skip this one run out of time
here okay so I want to brief this talk
about time series this was a part of the
reason
panas was originally developed to handle
time series data I'm just gonna give you
a mini tour of this Jake Vander Plaats
just did a recent blog on the Seattle
Bike Share so I said okay I'll take the
New York City bike share data I couldn't
find an easy way to W get this so I just
downloaded like one month whatever is
fine it actually these bikes your data's
are pretty good because they're they're
generally very easily importable so our
pipeline is really simple in this case
we're just going to say parse these
dates I added this inferred day time
format so the reason for this
so you'll notice the dates are like this
this is actually not it's very close to
an ISO lookin date sometimes of the
slashes so this is inferred day time
format we'll try to guess at your
formatting and it'll do things like put
different separators there so if it's
transformable in a very straightforward
way to ISO then you can parse it in a
highly efficient manner okay so here's
our data great again first thing I want
to do is look at my d types you know you
can tell if you imported it correctly or
not by looking at it I just very simply
if you have all objects then you did
something wrong if you have what you're
expecting then then you're happy okay so
again I'm going to do a simple thing
here let me do this here okay we're
gonna talk about resampling resampling
is just a group by based upon time
that's all it is it's a it's a it's a
group i with a time indexer okay so here
we're gonna start or take our set and
we're going to set the index to the time
fields called start time we're gonna
select out the bike ID field this is
actually in some sense arbitrary because
I'm all I'm interested in right now is
the counts I can group by on anything
doesn't matter
I want to resample to hourly so I'm
taking my
I'm chopping up in two hours
automatically and then I'm giving the
result okay in this case I'm just
counting counting how many non nuns are
in that group non knows okay nice plot I
could have done this in the in the
pipeline it just doesn't feel this page
if I do it that way but now I said okay
I want to do something a little more
sophisticated okay so let's let's just
walk through this example here again I'm
going to the reason I wrote the select
this is because I can do just like this
so we start with our original frame I'm
doing something fairly new here actually
I'm using this thing called grouper and
this allows me to embed a time blooper
inside a group by itself so I can have
one term which is essentially a wee
sampling term then another term which is
not okay this was used to not be
possible this is kind of cool because
you could say okay as I said before
don't try to do group by of group I and
that's what everybody would do they
would do resample and then inside the
resample they would give a function and
do something highly inefficient to do
that so in this case I'm going to group
simultaneously by the daily frequency of
start time and by the user type which i
think is customer or subscriber we're
going to count them oops okay great I
have the count each day for each to use
it okay and then I'm going to do a
series of operations here so first thing
I'm going to do I'm going to reset the
index so basically I'm going to turn
this back into a long-form looking type
data this was this was a series before
I'm gonna then pivot so I'm gonna go
Boop
okay
now this operation actually is I'm
showing what this actually should be but
reset index doesn't actually support the
other axis so I have to do some
transposes here okay that's kind of
boring what did I do I just renamed some
stuff as all I did okay and I get a nice
little plot here this is I think by day
which users you know custom you know I
think how many people are using it
something like that okay
but maybe I want to do something like I
wanna zoom in okay so this is
effectively like you know you have all
your nice visualization systems this is
effectively what they're doing they're
doing something like this they're taking
their initial intervals panas actually
allows you in a very convenient method I
say very it's convenient but it's sort
of unintuitive because what am I doing
here
I'm saying take all the dates that match
from the start date to the stop thing
I'm specifying this is a string if I'd
specify on them as a timestamp it'll
still work and that's actually gives you
exact intervals strings are effectively
like give me all the dates that start
with this through the end it's just it's
called partial string slicing it's very
convenient actually but here's the
here's the rub I'm actually doing this
I'm doing the slice on the rose but I'm
doing something which I traditionally
would be doing with normally I would be
accessing the columns here if I if I
give it like a list of variables those
are the columns so I'm doing something a
little bit odd here but this is was
designed this way we may eliminate this
at some point even though it is quite
convenient really what this should be is
that lock because then it's really
explicit what you're doing this way we
sort of have to guess the fact that you
have a time-based index means we're
gonna guess right Zack Lee it's very
explicit what you're doing here there's
some guessing going on now it's not so
out of the realm to guess however people
do this okay and you and expect it to
work it's not going to work you actually
this work the reason is because here
we're giving it a slice we're not giving
it you
so it's a little bit this is like a
little trip up which you don't want to
have to deal with it shouldn't work like
that it does that's okay so in any event
essentially what I did here is I
resampled this again the count and I
zoomed in is what I did it so he did the
first plot before but I zoomed in okay I
have no idea why the 10th to 11th of
September of this year was lower I just
it's like a Thursday I couldn't figure
out any reason then okay so you notice
that I use these things I used H and I
use D over there these are called
frequency objects and pet has a whole
suite of these a lot of people like date
manipulation so we provide lots of
little things like so when you can
construct a date by default is gonna be
daily but you can add our offsets if you
want you can even do things like this is
month start so what I'm doing is I'm
constructing a on index here and then
I'm saying okay give me the same time
but give me on the first of every month
and there's a myriad ways of doing these
things to construct exactly what you
want here's a month end and here you
know you can start in spring form you
can actually do this programmatically or
via strings just give me this arbitrary
frequency that I want it's a regular
frequency doesn't have to if you use
date range they'll give you a regular
frequency okay
just time zones time zones have been
substantially revamped in 17 they're now
highly efficient actually before these
would be stored as object data and so
they would be highly inefficient so I
created this effectively the d-type is
what it is to represent these and so now
in addition to have daytime 64
nanoseconds you can actually have a time
zone okay and you could of course do
things with that and again we're using
the dt accessors you can convert things
and you could even change them tonight
eve time zones are a whole separate
ballgame and we encourage you to read if
you need them read up on them funny the
anecdote from the mailing list is we
have there are three fellows who their
sole contribution is to discuss day time
daily seven times
transition issues and there's got to be
like 20 issues on this I mean you know
think about it how do you do it we can
resample over the times there you
include the exclude now all that said
pin is is quite good at this stuff I
mean we handle all kinds of time zone
stuff that which is just really really
gnarly it is it is terrible but no DTO
so i'm this is a series and dt is an
accessor okay it is a special construct
colic str or cat which allows you to
access I don't know if I have this
defined here let's see to access various
methods so you can I do that it's not
the fine okay various method in there
okay
time Delta's this briefly mention these
these are essentially a subtraction of
dates if you think about it okay I'm
just gonna give you now the reason these
are useful you could work with these
before these are a first class data type
as well and they represent you know
units a time either positive or negative
a lot of people like in physical type of
experiments they like to say okay I'm
starting at time zero and I'm proceeding
forward there's no date associated with
that you could but it's not relevant for
that for that use case so time Delta's
become interesting for that the reason
we're also interested in them is if you
have data like that you can of course so
you can do our arithmetic with them
convert them into seconds things like
that I'm going to show you here's the
example this is not interesting okay
skip that okay so I'm going to show you
another example of resampling going back
to what we were talking about before
pretend you have I think I did a
thousand periods here in the first first
one second of the market okay
pretend you're trading and you're doing
that that's like the say dollar market
randomly here and so you can do things
like you can resample and we'll we have
a lot of predefined functions that are
very fast things like ohlc so the open
high low close and we'll just do this
for you
this is like defined insight on very
easy you can also put your own function
here so you can you can give a lambda
here
you generally don't want to do this you
know some whatever you want to do as
this will again just be called on each
of those groups but this is just another
example I'm I didn't even cover this but
missing values so oftentimes what
happens is so your resampling data or
whatever and you have holes in your data
you have Nan's pan is actually quite
good at handling the ends and it's it
handles Nan's and your dates it handles
Nan's in your float data not energy data
right the second it's going too soon and
you can fill and there's various methods
of filling you can interpolate you can
do all kinds of things this in this
particular case is just a fill forward
okay there's a lot of cool things that
are buried in the docks
these are computational tools so we call
these things like doing a rolling mean
so this is effectively if you think
about it it's a transformation on time
or on a window actually rolled so it's
kind of like a moving group by in fact
I'm gonna change the interface for this
in 18 so it'll be it'll look really much
like that actually but for now a lot of
loud goodies in there okay
now my last thing here we're out of time
okay so there's a lot of people use
pandas just you know to munch data and
then do their own analysis on it great
however a lot of people I'll say our
down stream of pandas things like here
I'll give my nice little this is my
picture from before things like
scikit-learn or stats models or or - say
you're working on some bigger data okay
so we have a concert of upstream -
example tasks which we'll go through in
a second is both upstream and downstream
so we can use it for compute or people
can use on a higher level with a pandas
like interface and it actually uses
pandas where scikit-learn purely takes
data frames but you might they might be
part of the pipeline in fact if you were
at Andy's talk this morning this is you
know a huge part of processing is taking
your raw data doing bunches of
transformations and then bunch of
analysis and keep going and then
eventually when I helped put it so
pandas is generally part of this
pipeline okay
so we're just gonna briefly show a
little example through these and I'll
show you some performance stuff the end
okay
let's zoom back in here okay so this is
just using scikit-learn I'm not doing
anything sophisticated here at all
I'm simply I'm gonna read some stuff in
and I'm gonna this is this is the red
button I just hit the button and get
some results and right now this is this
is going to change apparently in a new
version of psych and learn but right now
this way I get back oh this is awful and
I get back this like you know list of
weird stuff okay so this is gonna be
fixed this is my little unpacker to get
it back to something that I care about
so pandas is useful here it's not that
useful in the sense that I have to you
know do some looping and everything but
it's useful for you know transforming my
my results of my experiments back to
something that I can actually deal with
and do further statistics on okay
and of course what would I want to do
that I want to type into something else
or maybe do some transformation or
whatever or plotting okay I can do the
same thing stats models stats models is
also a great library here I'm gonna read
in some data that we did previously
there's a couple of quirks and stats
models it actually is highly it
understands pan is a lot especially in
its time series models but it has little
quirks like you know when you have
true/false values you have to make them
integers okay that's fine and we could
just shove it again I'm using the my
same exact syntax and I'm going to plug
it right to there do some fitting get a
nice summary great okay here's another
eye music we're using Patsy internally
in this in this slide here to to
actually use our formally interface so
that's pretty cool and they do the same
thing okay
now I'm gonna show you I'm just gonna
end on I have a little time here so
pandas is very friendly to using scythe
on it's also very friendly to using
numba it'll be even more friendly in the
future but for right now I'm gonna give
you an example of why you would want to
even do this so this is a function that
does ewm a so exponential weighted
moving average I almost literally copied
this from our Docs I did cut out some
stuff and I'll tell you why in a second
this essentially you know in if you'd
write this in Python it is pretty slow
but it's readable but pretty slow I'm
going to write the same exact thing in
scythe on and it's almost a copy-paste
yeah we have a couple of identifies here
the one thing to note
so in scythe on I have to allocate my
memory run my function and then I'm
gonna wrap it okay
I'm gonna do the same I mean I'm so I'm
we're gonna call that scythe on number
one and this is size number two it's
actually calling from the Panda zwa
function just for comparison purposes
it's actually written in scythe on as
well here I'm going to call number
number is I'm gonna do the same thing
actually I did with the scythe on you
don't actually have to do this in the
new version it will actually allocate
the memory and return it to you but
we're just for comparison purposes want
to make the same and you have to wrap it
in series in the future we're going to
support the ability to pass a take your
series pass into a number function and
return it as a series directly so you
won't have to do any of this little it's
a little bit of boilerplate not bad but
again you know that the code I just
chugged JIT on it that's all I did
here's I just I'm confirming that all
the results are the same
that's important because otherwise then
you're comparing apples and oranges and
that's bad okay so python is pretty slow
that i think this is even a small series
I'm doing scythe ons you know quite a
bit faster surprisingly pandas is slower
it's interesting and and number is also
quite fast the reason pandas are slower
is because we're not doing null checking
in the example
I had so takes a little bit of time to
do that important a little bit of time
but so before I get to desk I'm so we're
gonna have some hooks basically in panas
to be able to easily shove your stuff
right to number and again we're going to
make it as transparent as possible it
won't be completely transparent because
example unlike say like bottleneck or
num Express which we automatically use
if they're available number has things
like you may want to know if like you're
doing something funky in your function
and we just cannot compile this so we go
back to know Python mode and that's what
you want and so the choice is do I raise
and say okay hey this totally blew up or
do I allow you to actually pass the flag
to say okay hey I still want to do it so
it might be a slightly different
interface but we'll get there
similarly when you want to deal with out
of cord data or when you are paralyzed
things task is a great solution to this
it has a very nice pandas like interface
so here I'm actually I'm creating a data
frame I'm doing this method from pandas
I'm using tasks here and it gives me a
desk data frame essentially to ask is it
has a view kind of a view on a data
frame and it chops it up to the blocks
and then you can operate in these blocks
in parallel you can also do dependency
graph stuff we're not gonna get into
that I think Jim Chris has a talk later
today on that so the answer is yes okay
okay the question was does desk handle
data frames don't fit in them and the
answer is yes so in effect what you
would do there's a couple of good
examples and I know Jim will point these
out later today you have your data say
sitting in files whatever it you
basically can read it using the desk
routines
it doesn't actually read the data until
you're ready to compute with it it will
read it it will chunk it and then it can
paralyze this and you do all the
dependency graph stuff it's pretty cool
actually
so in pandas we're actually thinking
about again providing a sort of an easy
way to hey let's just Auto paralyze
stuff that we know is gonna work so
here's an example of something that we
might want to do
so we do a group I and this is a fairly
big frame by going to desk I can get
this done in a multi-threaded way and
this is one of the reasons we released
the Gil in order to enable this and I
get a free speed up for free I'm not
doing anything else you won't even know
it'll just work and I think that's a
nice benefit that pandas can provide I
think I have a graph up here okay I have
a few minutes left any questions anybody
no question there but he knows at all
okay so I have another talk which I'll I
should post link to so here's some
things you should really never do
don't use apply if you can avoid it in
any way shape or form don't use apply
it's essentially like a loop
another thing I've seen a lot is if you
have a bunch of say you're creating a
bunch of frames and you need to contact
them don't do it in the loop itself okay
what you want to do is just simply put
them in a list and then concatenate is
basically every operation was pure so
it's gonna copy stuff and give you back
a new copy this is a very convenient
interface it's nice you know there's no
side effects but example when you do
this in a loop and you've gotten you'll
you'll exponentially copy stuff bad what
else do people do ah
so if you have if you sometimes you want
to get your access to your numpy arrays
so if you if you have a data frame and
you access the series and then you do
dot values on that you're gonna get back
the numpy array itself okay or view on
actually great perfect however generally
you want to hold mixed types in your
data frames the second you call dot
values on that I'm gonna give you back
an object I'll give you one I'll give
you an umpire right but it might be up
casted and say you have strings and
floats this is bad so I'm gonna show you
a quick example here
let's see I can't even do this here
can everybody see that when you zoom in
a little bit here
okay okay and so if I do D F dot a great
this is an umpire array okay but if I do
this it works but I get an object array
so immediately you're losing your
efficiency they so you need to think
about these type of things anybody else
so the question was if I have a legacy
data format what are the options to
exposing it well to pandas export to CSV
you know these are unfortunately there's
somewhat specific questions I mean the
most common things that people keep
dating and we can read directly but if
it's a legacy data format you need some
sort of converter if you can migrate
your data that's a great thing to do not
great solutions say I get I mean you can
certainly create some functions to read
and write it I mean in your own library
in fact I've seen I think these are the
physics physics guys they read this
format called route or something like
that and you know certainly there's a
ton of formats out there we you know
we've discussed because you want to make
it a nice interface right so we've
discussed actually having like some
people could have a library of those out
there and we could just you can just
patch him in at runtime if you want you
can make a package which does this just
to have a nice interface on them I guess
the goop rocks don't really have data
types that what they're doing is they're
holding on to basically two things one
is the original object and then two is a
reference to essentially which grow
which rows belong to which groups so
whenever you're doing this flexion what
happens is we're saying okay you pull up
that original data so it's whatever it
was okay so whatever you're actually
grouping on it's just a subset of that
the same okay yeah
um you could actually do things like so
you could alternatively convert this to
you could do this you can make it you
can make a wreck or a which is slightly
more useful I mean this is the you know
the only problem of this is I mean you
notice this is like in conceptually it's
pretty simple right it's it's basically
it has a D type of composite D type so
this is almost like a data frame
actually we think about it I don't see
people using these so so much but you
can use them and actually when we store
things like in PI tables actually we
export to things like this and this is
how they're actually written to R or
ended format
so this is really wholly depend upon
numpy and unfortunately that's views are
extremely convenient there are cases
where it'll actually give you a view if
it can put it that way
and that's sort of the rub it's like I
don't necessarily want to have an
operation that is dependent on what
actual data I have at the time
you want an operation to be data
independent and that's why this these
are extremely convenient but they
violate this principle
unfortunately the user has to know too
much so the answer is yes any other
questions all right so that's it I'll be
around a little bit if you guys have any
more questions